we start today with a stunning speech
from President Joe Biden last night
defending democracy Joe Biden had to
give a speech saying democracy is a good
thing and we should work to keep it and
we should fight against the people that
want to destroy it and to want to tear
it down imagine that imagine a situation
in 2022 almost 2023 United States where
we have a movement in the country so
unhinged but also so powerful not
overwhelmingly powerful they didn't
succeed in 2020 but they didn't come
that far let's be honest a movement
powerful enough in its extremism and
unhinged nature
that the current president on the
proverbial Eve not the literal Eve but
the proverbial Eve of the 2022 midterms
a president who won even though they say
he lost by the way had to come out and
defend democracy and argue we shouldn't
become violent to overthrow democracy
that's a bad thing
it is a disgusting reality that we have
to face that this is where we are in
almost 2023. let's start with Joe Biden
very clearly talking about what is the
origin of this problem
you know American democracy under attack
because
the defeated former president of the
United States refused to accept the
results of the 2020 election
he refuses to accept the will of the
people
he refuses to accept the fact that he
lost
he has abused his power and put the
loyalty to himself before lord of the
Constitution
and he's made a big lie
an article of faith in the Maga
Republican party indeed the minority of
that party
the great irony about half of the party
let's be fair
about the 220 election
is that it's the most attacked election
in our history and yet and yet
there's no election in our history
that we can be more certain of its
results yeah we can be completely sure
that Joe Biden genuinely won and Joe
Biden not only putting the blame and the
responsibility squarely on Trump and
Maga but also pointing out that this is
an extremely consequential midterm
election which is something I've been
saying at this point for a year or
longer I know there's a lot of stake in
these midterm elections from our economy
the safety of our streets to our
personal freedoms the future of Health
Care Social Security Medicare it's all
important
but we'll have our differences we have
our difference of opinion
and that's what's supposed to be
but there's something else at stake
right democracy itself
I'm not the only one who sees it
recent polls have shown that
overwhelming majority of Americans
believe our democracy at risk is at risk
that our democracy is under threat
they too see that democracy is on the
ballot this year these are the types of
speeches that often
opposition leaders give
in dictatorships okay
it is out of this world cuckoo that this
is the type of speech that Joe Biden
finds himself giving and he could the
we're going to get to how the right wing
was triggered by this speech he made
clear even when it comes to January 6th
that was not the end of the assault on
democracy and as you know if you've been
following this show there are dozens if
not more Republicans running right now
on the ballot
who deny the results of the election
look even as I speak here tonight
27 million people have already cast
their ballot
in the midterm elections
Millions more will cast their ballots in
the final days leading up to November
the 9th 8th excuse me
and for the first time
this is the first time since the
national election of 2020.
once again we're seeing record turnout
all over the country
and that's good
we want Americans to vote
we want every American's voice to be
heard
now we have to move the process forward
we know that more and more ballots are
cast in early voting or by mail in
America
and we know
that many states don't start counting
those ballots so after the polls close
on November 8th
that means in some cases we won't know
the winner of the election
for a few days until after a few days
after the election
takes time to count all legitimate
ballots
an illegal and orderly manner
it's always been important for Citizens
and democracy to be informed and engaged
now it's important for citizen to be
patient as well
that's how it's supposed to work
this is also the first election since
the events of January 6th
when the armed angry mob stormed the US
Capitol
I wish I wish I could say the assault on
a democracy it ended that day it didn't
but I cannot
as I stand here today there are
candidates running for every level of
office in America for governor Congress
Attorney General Secretary of State
who won't commit that will not commit to
accepting the results of the election
that they're running in in fact they're
saying if I lose it's rigged if I win
it's fair Joe Biden also addressing the
rise in the number of people who are
saying violence to achieve your
political goals is okay
we have to be honest with ourselves
though
we have to face this problem
we can't turn away from it
we can't pretend it's just going to
solve itself
there's an alarming rise in the number
of our people
in this country condoning political
violence yeah or simply remaining
silence because silence is complicity
the disturbing rise of voter
intimidation
pernicious tendency to excuse political
violence or at least at least trying to
explain it away
we can't allow this sentiment to grow
we must confront it head on now
it has to stop now
I believe the voices
excusing are calling for violence and
intimidation are distinct minority in
America I do not know well a minority in
America let's hope so a minority in the
Republican party I'm not quite sure and
unfortunately many of the people
minimizing the January 6 Trump riots
uh uh not necessarily welcoming but
certainly inspiring the uh perceived
legitimacy of political violence in the
minds of their supporters
many of them could win and some of them
probably will uh President Biden going
on to connect Trump's big lie
on the attack on Paul Pelosi and they
are connected and all this happened
after the assault
and it's just I if I try hard to even
say
it's hard to even say after the
assailant entered the home asking
where's Nancy
where's Nancy
those are the very same words used by
the mob when they storm the United
States capital on January the 6th
literally when they broke windows
kicked in the doors
brutally attacked law enforcement roam
the Carters hunting for officials
and erected Gallows to hang the former
vice president Mike Pence
it was an enraged mob that had been
whipped up into a frenzy by a president
repeating over and over again
the big lie
that the election of 2020 had been
stolen it is indeed the exact same line
that you follow through those phenomena
Joe Biden warning ahead of time as I
mentioned before that it will take some
time to count all of the legitimate
ballots and that that's okay and then
eventually Biden closing by saying uh
the following year we're often not faced
with questions of whether the vote we
cash will preserve democracy or put us
at risk
but this year we are
this year
I hope you'll make the future of our
democracy an important part of your
decision to vote and how you vote
I hope you'll ask a simple question of
each candidate you might vote for
will that person accept a legitimate
will of the American people and people
voting in his district or her District
yeah it's shocking that that's the Top
Line question we have to ask they're a
group there you've got the candidates
who have their policy and they will
accept the results of the election and
then you've got the candidates that will
not that's a major dividing line who
respects the will of the voter here
will that person accept the outcome of
the election win or lose
the answer to that question is vital
and in my opinion it should be decisive
and the answer to that question
hangs the future of the country we love
so much and the fate of the Democracy it
has made so much possible for us yeah uh
a good speech
a really dystopian reality in which such
a speech is necessary and logical so Joe
Biden did a few important things here
other than defend the idea that we
thought we had a democracy we should
probably work to try to keep that he
issued a sort of warning about
Republicans planning to undermine the
vote on Tuesday and we're going to have
Clips later on and on tomorrow's show of
ways in which they are already doing
this and other examples so the
Republicans are already doing that
they're making it clear they're
telegraphing they're going to be doing
that on Tuesday Joe Biden sort of trying
to sound the alarm in advance the way we
were doing and many in Progressive media
were doing in advance of the 2020
election it was very clear what Trump
was going to do and at two something in
the morning on Election night 2020 he
did he came out and said oh I won even
though he had not won and then the other
thing is he's setting expectations about
it'll take a few days in some of these
elections to know the results
particularly because in some of these
places they don't actually start
counting anything until the polls close
there will be a whole but Pennsylvania
is an example actually I don't remember
if Pennsylvania doesn't start until a
polls close but they stop at a
particular time a whole bunch of
accumulated mail-in and early ballots
will be there but they will not start to
be counted until post close in many
cases at 8 pm local time so an important
speech very sad that he had to make it
let's now look at the reactions from the
right
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
hold on bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below